y at il réellement un rapport entre
bourse économie réelle vous vous dites
oui évidemment sauf que ce n'est pas
forcément si évident que ça la preuve la
banque des règlements internationaux
mais aussi le régulateur des marchés
financiers européens ou encore le fmi
ont récemment mis en garde sur ce sujet
car si le choc avait été bien présent au
mois de mars au début de la pandémie
les marchés financiers ont depuis fait
un spectaculaire rebond retrouvent
presque leur niveau d'avant crise
quand l'économie réelle peine à repartir
avec une pandémie toujours en cours et
la crainte d'une deuxième vague voire
d'un nouveau confinement
l'explication réside essentiellement
dans le rôle des banques centrales qui
ont injecté des milliards et des
milliards pour éviter la catastrophe
du coup sur les marchés on n'a plus
vraiment peur on sait que l'eau
bienveillante banques centrales seront
toujours là en cas de plongeon pour les
rattraper et réinjecter du cash
certaines entreprises au premier rang
les fameuses gars femme ou aussi su
tirer leur épingle du jeu grâce à
l'utilisation renforcée du numérique
depuis le confinement encore plus
cynique les licenciements et pertes
d'emplois contribueraient elle aussi à
augmenter la valeur de certaines
entreprises en bourse licenciement égale
diminution des coûts de l'entreprise et
garantir une marge plus importante lors
de la reprise
un calcul selon lequel l'amélioration de
la rentabilité devrait compenser la
demande détruite par les pertes
d'emplois